Dragon Ball is unique and not just
because of its spiky-haired Giga
forehead characters from Japan to
America to even little old Ireland over
here it's a story with Worldwide appeal
like no other but where it really breaks
the mold is an aspect that varies from
country to Country series to series hell
even company to company and that aspect
is of course the music
where most shows may have only one
composer or maybe a couple depending on
how many series a story has Dragon Ball
has no such consistency the original
score the English replacement score the
other English replacement score the GT
score the other other English
replacement score the super score the
other other replacement English score it
is almost baffling how little musical
consistency this story has over the
course of its now multi-decade lifetime
anime replacement scores were all the
rage in the 1990s but replacement scores
aren't simply unique to the hello fellow
kids attitude of Western anime
Publishers even something as recent as
the Justice League movie received a
complete rescore between its Wheaton cut
and the Snyder cut but the fact is that
just about any time an existing work
gets its music replaced one of the
versions is a largely declared the
overwhelming correct music while the
other is cast aside Into Obscurity in
the case of Justice League even though
the whedon-led Danny the Elfman score
hit theaters first you would be
hard-pressed to find too many people
that prefer it over the junkie XL score
found in the Snyder cut so why then why
does every single Dragon Ball scorer
have its absolute die-hard fans how does
the show get away with jumping from one
sound to the next at the drop of a hat
and still largely have its music beloved
by many well I spent the last couple of
weeks diving deep into the history of
every single composer for Dragon Ball it
was a lot of work and not only do I
think I have the answer to that very
question but I think the story of these
composers says something much more
profound about not only soundtracks but
art itself so strap in folks because in
preparation for my upcoming long-awaited
Dragon Ball Z review series we are
diving deep into the wild and Wacky
World of Dragon Balls musical composers
ladies and gentlemen we have a
surprising number of composers to talk
about today each with their own span of
the show they covered history unique
sound and place in the story and where
better to start chronologically than the
original the one and the only shinsuke
kakuchi
foreign
of Dragon Ball right through to when
Goku forgot he had a family and left a
train oop Kikuchi covered everything
even down to the movies and tv specials
but his anime Adventures began long
before Dragon Ball producing music for
the likes of tiger mask get a robo
Doraemon and the list goes on in fact
kakuchi's collaboration with Toriyama
didn't even begin with Dragon Ball the
man has been around since the doctor
slump days and with a quick listen to
his back catalog it's clear this is a
man who knows what he excels at crack
open the soundtrack to any of the anime
I just listed and you will hear that
kakuchi has always had a very distinct
style taking advantage of small Studio
Orchestra his compositions are all but
quintessentially 80s light-hearted anime
Vibes vibrant string sections powerful
horns xylophones wacky drums slap bass
Kikuchi used just about every of the
error tool at his disposal to craft
these wonderful pieces of music and with
his junk to dragon ball this approach
remained the same wakakuchi saw in this
series was the very same thing many fans
at home saw a fun story of a Fearless
boy full of Adventure and mysticism
[Music]
foreign
his approach to the show remained fairly
steadfast for pretty much the entire
Original Dragon Ball series steeped in
Chinese influence wusha films and Kung
Fu Madness but one thing we should talk
about is the concept of instrumentation
put simply instrumentation is just what
sorts of instruments and sounds you use
to create a piece of music but what's
important to understand is that what
instruments you use to bring a
composition to life is a whole separate
piece from the composition itself clip
your emo fringes on for just a second
and think back to the song never meant
[Music]
what notes and rhythms are inside of it
are one thing but how it sounds is also
determined by the instrumentation and
sounds they chose to bring those notes
to life take the very same Melody and
throw in some Bluegrass instrumentation
or even Mario 64 instrumentation and it
becomes something very different the
choice of instruments drastically
changes the overall feed feel of the
song and composition and those choices
apply to every single composer I will
talk about today on top of his usual
approach to instrumentation Kikuchi
whipped out some new sounds for Dragon
Ball that have gone on to become
synonymous with the property spring
sounds slide whistles the extra iconic
Vibra slap he really spiced up his usual
formula to create a unique sound for
Dragon Ball from the outset one that
makes the grand with the Goofy and as
the anime crept into the King Piccolo
era kakuchi began to dive deeper into
the world of motifs or themes for lack
of a better term in other words some
characters or concepts had their own
theme music while he didn't make use of
these themes quite as often as some of
the other composers on this list when he
did oh boy did it go
laughs
by the time Dragon Ball Z rolled around
kikuchi's approach to the series had
sort of evolved to match the evolution
of the series itself where the show had
moved from a lighthearted adventure to a
more grisly tale of Space Monkeys and
Galactic genocide so too did Kikuchi
move to more dire music especially in
terms of his fight tracks what's
interesting is that much of kikuchi's
music was composed for the dragon ball
movies and then repurposed into the main
show alongside the TV exclusive
compositions this was true all the way
back in OG Dragon Ball but is especially
pivotal in the Z era where a great many
of his most beloved and Powerful tracks
in the anime were originally composed
for the movies
but this is where things get interesting
because what kakuchi's score for the
show may have started out as a largely
Chinese influenced the further he went
into Z the more that shifted and would
you believe me if I told you the
direction he ended up going with the
most for Z was actually very Western
influenced and I don't mean westerners
in Europe and America and all that kind
of stuff I mean literally old school
western movies Yeehaw shout outs at High
Noon and Clint Eastwood that sort of
shebang it's not something that you
probably think of when you think of
Dragon Ball Z as Japanese music but the
influences are all over the place while
there are definitely more musically
fundamental influences I could point to
you don't even need to dig that deep by
the final stages of Z the music was so
Western that I could swear a tumbleweed
was going to Sail by while Vegeta
monologues here
[Music]
foreign
Dragon Ball he is as much a part of
Dragon Ball as Toriyama or masuko nazawa
the unmistakable identity that he
brought to the series is something that
is really hard to overstate he did so
much I mean it's just insane over 500
individual pieces of music over the
course of around a decade all evolving
with the story were appropriate his
tenure in the world of Goku and KO is
legendary but then
why is this not the end of the video
well
jumping into 1996 Z just wrapped up in
Japan and America's finally ready to
give this series its big push
funimation's first attempt with original
Dragon Ball didn't work with only minor
changes so what did gen fukunaga decide
to do next well he teamed up with the
Canadian ocean group to work on
retooling the show and with that came a
drastic overhaul to the music welcome to
the stage Ron Wasserman
[Music]
not only did Wasserman compose the
iconic Rock the dragon but the entire
portion of this ocean funny save and run
from Raditz through to Ginyu I'm sure
many of you now are going hold up isn't
Shuki Levi the one who did this stuff
and you wouldn't be wrong if you simply
looked at the credits but plot twist
Wasserman actually composed those pieces
uncredited for reasons unknown to me but
possibly something to do with rights and
royalty access but hey I'm sure on
credited composers won't be a recurring
theme or anything later this isn't the
first time Wasserman has worked with
Saban either though remember go go Power
Rangers well that's him but actually
unlike his work in this era that
supported your typical 90s cartoony
power rock tunes wasserman's music for Z
was a total swerve the score was frantic
Spacey otherworldly and whether that was
his direction or someone from above's
someone on the team saw this series as a
big old sci-fi Space Opera
what's kind of crazy is that in spite of
this big shift in tone the music was
largely well received at the time as was
the product as a whole I mean this thing
has drastically different
characterization and wacky censorship on
top of this insane music but actually I
think this unrestrained retooling is why
people vibed with it so much it all
meshed together in a way that was
coherent in spite of being so different
and I think that's the key
replaced with a certain mustachioed fan
favorite this musical approach will
serve as the blueprint for almost every
American score on the series going
forward
[Music]
that's right the year is still 1996. wow
Dragon Ball composers were busy in that
year weren't they and surprise Goku is a
kid again and Vegeta has grown a
mustache in honor of a certain U.S
composer but what's this our beloved
Kikuchi has retired and now for the
first time Dragon Ball needs a new sound
bring on akihito tokunaga
[Music]
thank you
so uh now would be the time to talk
about tokonago's vast history of
composing but
I can't because he doesn't have any what
so it turns out when toei hired him for
Dragon Ball GT this man had composed
nothing he was just a bassist in some
band and I mean he has some songwriting
credits here and there but that was kind
of it I have searched high and low to
try to understand why he was hired in
the first place but my best guess is
that because he composed some music for
the band zard of whom did GT's second
ending as well as wrote the lyrics for
the opening so I guess he got in that
way maybe I I really have no idea but I
think that's what makes this guy so
interesting I mean imagine being in this
position you're playing bass in some
band and then all of a sudden you're
given the hell to the successor of one
of the most popular shows in the world
like what this guy was thrown right into
the deep end charged with composing a
score for both the GT and the big
anniversary movie path to power
simultaneously that's an unfathomable
level of stress and yet he dove in head
first
foreign
s aren't exactly spectacular reception
for the Dragon Ball GT score was
middling at best and even today it's
hardly noteworthy compared to its
contemporaries while his approach isn't
too dissimilar to kikuchi's in terms of
tone and instrumentation Choice his work
with synthesized instrumentation
compared with kikuchi's real deal left
things feeling understandably flat in
comparison and What Hurts the Most is
really just how short his story is after
movie in those initial TV compositions
his contributions to the show completely
ceased even a new track on the GT
special was just an unused piece from
his original run from the beginning
through to the end the series reused
peace after peace to the point that it
really began to sour audiences on it
like imagine writing fun and adventurous
tunes for the lighthearted first Arc
only to have it reused in the final Arc
where my boy Vegeta is being shish kebab
I mean it's not exactly ideal GT's
production has always been a strange one
of uncertainty and ever-changing
approaches but unfortunately
documentation on the music remains
lacking tokunaga still writes and
performs in his band to this very day so
it does certainly seem like they heard
his initial output weren't into it and
dropped him like a ton of bricks I
personally may not love his music for
the show but that's still a thought that
saddens me he was never really given the
chance to see it through and evolve his
craft an opportunity afforded to a
certain someone on the other side of the
world later but for now I must ask you
to strap in for arguably the most
fascinating score covered today the year
is now 1999 and over in the land of
apple pie an incorrectly named football
FUNimation has decided trips to Canada
are too much effort and expensive and so
in true capitalist fashion they've
called their ocean group relationship
and decided to produce their own dub for
cheap in-house and with those new voice
actors came the mustache man himself
Bruce Faulkner
[Music]
thank you
this man right here took over the Dragon
Ball Z score from Ginyu all the way to
the end of Z and has cemented himself in
the western world as one of the most
recognizable and iconic parts of Dragon
Ball Z born in Dallas Texas to a Naval
aviator father he wait a second who are
these guys well the long and fascinating
history of the Faulkner Productions
composers and credit woes is big enough
that you'll get a full rundown in its
own dedicated video in the future but
let's get one thing straight you see
these names these guys are the actual
composers for 99 of the Faulkner score
you may know and love Mr mustache
actually composed only a few tracks for
the show's entire run and despite this
his name is all over the various CDs and
credits lists despite their unique and
Rich history the three composers who
created this now Famous soundtrack are
largely unknown to the greater fandom
thanks to this distinct lack of clear
crediting wait maybe this is a recurring
theme with this takeover during the
namak arc it was initially only Mr Smith
at the helm producing music very much in
line with the predecessor Ron Wasserman
so much so that I honestly wouldn't be
surprised if that was a requirement from
above to smooth over the transition for
the audiences but hey don't get me wrong
this wasn't simply a copycat situation
either Smith sure put his own spin on
things by pushing that 90 sound to the
max with a wide array of awesome synths
pads and all the crazy awesomeness
associated with this era
[Music]
he really favored Melody driven Affairs
which is not only conducive to memorable
music but played a key part in him
creating some of the show's most iconic
themes I mean this score as a whole is
truly theme Central and I think that's a
large part as to why it stayed in the
English-speaking fandom's Consciousness
for decades now the Dragon Ball theme
Vegeta's theme the Super Saiyan theme
Gohan's theme whatever theme comes to
mind there's a very good chance it was
Mike Smith who put it together of course
Smith wasn't the only name on this list
though and as the show progressed the
group found themselves with another
composer in their ranks Scott heavy
metal Morgan his work really started in
full swing once we left the Frieza Arc
and where Mike was all about Melody
Scott was all about mood dark and
ethereal this man's music truly set the
tone for whatever scene they appeared in
where Smith would pen a wild piano riff
for Vegeta's Super Saiyan theme Morgan
would take a wildly different approach
to character themes
what's kind of neat is that out of all
the composers on this roster Scott
Morgan was the only one who could play
guitar so if you ever hear one ripping
and tearing up the score you'll know for
certain it's him and oh boy did those
skills lead to some incredibly intense
scenes
as the show hit the boo Arc the team
gained its final composer Julius dobos
this man has a long history of working
with synthesized music already and he
put that into immediate use here almost
Reinventing the sound of the score in
this Arc ironically though this
reinvention made things less synthetic
instead bringing in aspects like
traditional horns and strings to the mix
resulting in the entire crew doing
something entirely new
but perhaps the most unique element of
this score comes from the constraints
they were given gen fukunaga insisted
the music be non-stop wall-to-wall in
its placement no silence allowed and as
a result the gang took a lot of care to
write much of their music to scene if
you're not aware most scores for a TV
series are written independently of
what's going on on screen instead
building up a pool of music for various
types of scenes that a director can pull
from to use where appropriate The Only
Exception often being for important
scenes where the composer will pull up
an episode and compose to the specific
timing of that scene in the Faulkner
scores case the Cinematic approach of
composing the footage was not the
exception but the norm pieces were
written to transition seamlessly and the
team would often reinvent previous
tracks to specifically match unique
character beats sometimes that would
even mean a particular track played once
in the entire show say what you will
about whether the score fits Dragon Ball
or not but this team really gave it
their absolute all and it truly shows
the score is genuinely one of the most
fascinating on the list today not just
because of its crazy credit Scandal or
replacement score ethic debates but
because it's the only one on the list
with multiple composers that in and of
itself makes it unique and want to kind
of zoomed through these details today
know that the more you dive into this
the more interesting It ultimately
becomes more than Wasserman or even
tokunaga I think the score proved that
the world of Dragon Ball can support a
wide variety of sounds while many will
argue it succeeded because it was more
suited to Western audiences I think
kakuchi's prevalence in every other
Western Country shows that not to be the
case this score actually succeeds on its
own merits because those involved
genuinely poured their heart and soul
into every step of the production and so
now like all good anime this story comes
with a Time skip the year is 2005 and an
American composer is about to live out
the very existence tokunaga was denied
this is Nathan Johnson
[Music]
thank you
so tell me if this one sounds familiar
composing credits before dragon ball
Zero legitimate reasons to be hired to
compose for Dragon Ball zero reception
of their initial work not great yep you
got it Nathan Johnson is tokunaga 2.0
the story behind is being hired for the
show is somehow the most insane one yet
in 2005 FUNimation decided to redub the
Wasserman era episodes with their
in-house voice cast and naturally needed
a new replacement score to match out of
options and desperate for answers one
day a FUNimation exec was talking to one
of his tenants for a house he was
landlording over and well this guy said
he owned a keyboard and would love to do
music and that was it I wish I was
joking but this is straight from the
horse's mouth Johnson got hired on as a
complete fluke and with absolutely zero
professional experience his work on the
show was well I think this is probably
the chunk of music that has the fewest
fans of anyone I'll talk about today
[Music]
his approach seemed to more or less be
the same as the Ethereal synth heavy
Wasserman score that he was replacing
and while that makes sense from a
logistical standpoint you don't want
your replacement score to be too jarring
to those who watch the older dog back in
the day let's just say his
Johnson diverge because where tokunaga
will seemingly cast aside after a bad
initial outing FUNimation stuck with
Johnson for a good while after his
initial poor work in the Saiyan Saga he
was tasked with doing the resource for a
bunch of the Z movies with each
successive outing he became more and
more familiar with the show itself and
better as a result he focused on more
traditional orchestral sounds honed his
writing and mixing abilities and started
to really Shine by the time Fusion
Reborn rolled around he was producing a
score so well regarded that I don't
think a lot of English fans even realize
that it's a replacement score with Wrath
of the Dragon the show said goodbye to
Johnson and goodbye to the practice of
replacement scores the music departments
were being shot and the industry moved
to keep anime's original music but I
think this final score here was a great
farewell not just as a great story of
redemption for the man but as a
genuinely excellent piece of film score
powerful string Melodies timpanies all
sorts of impactful sounds were brought
together for this very score Johnson
even learned to play the Ocarina for
composing his tapion theme
stole from me everything precious and
dear but no more
the transformation from where he began
to where he ended up is just remarkable
it's a fate that I wish we could have
seen tokunaga live out but I'm glad
nonetheless that Johnson was given the
chance to walk his path and evolve his
craft of course nowadays he is a literal
state senator but I'd be willing to bet
he could still whip up a mean movie
score if he so chose and with that we
have officially finished off our Dragon
Ball Z composers but as you know Dragon
Ball didn't end there in fact before
Dragon Ball super business the series
saw a
Revival of Dragon Ball Kai wait
that that's still Z and for this Big
Revival toy brought in Sleeper Agent
Kenji Yamamoto
out of everyone on this list Yamamoto
has by far the most storied history with
Dragon Ball upon his hiring none of this
had never heard of the show before
business Yamamoto came onto Kai having
already worked with the series for over
two decades for years he had been the
go-to composer for pretty much every
Dragon Ball video game in existence as
well as a composer for a big chunk of
the original Show's insert songs
Yamamoto had been with dragon ball for
so long at this point he was almost as
synonymous with the series as Kikuchi so
it was a Natural Choice to bring him on
for Kai and once he started it did not
take him long to get going having that
level of familiarity with the franchise
really allowed him to burst onto the
scene and make an immediate impression
on all who watched his score was big
Grand bombastic and almost filmic horn
strings drums cello the whole soundscape
came together to create a score that
felt like what those before it tried and
failed to sort of achieve from high
energy fight tracks to genuinely
emotional beats he really hit it all
[Music]
foreign
ly though for how beloved this score is
among fans of all generations there are
a lot and I mean a lot of asterixes with
Yamamoto and his Kai score the first and
most obvious one is that well if you
watched Kion Blu-ray there's a good
chance you simply have never heard his
music before Yamamoto scored the entire
original Kai series all the way through
to sell but years later some videos over
on the Japanese web started going viral
videos that compared and highlighted
that a lot of his music was completely
plagiarized and I'm not talking isolated
incidents either even as far back as his
insert songs in the 1980s this man was
taking existing tracks and just copy
pasting them onto Dragon Ball
[Music]
these comparison Clips really took off
in Japan which alerted toei to his
stealing and led to them replacing his
Kai score with reuse Kikuchi music how
about that a replacement score using an
original score but again it really is
insane how often and direct these
plagiarized songs were for Kai it is
just everywhere
and yet that still isn't the end of the
asterix's for poor Kenji even aside from
his plagiarism or perhaps as a direct
result of it the other major failing
with his Chi score is how short the
track count actually is for his entire
Saiyan to sell run he only managed to
produce a few dozen tracks for the show
which naturally meant the directors had
very little to work with as far as
making sure the music was diverse enough
to fit the scene worse still of the
tracks that he did create many of them
did not live up to the best of his
output and couldn't really be used in
most cases to begin with so all in all
you ended up with a stolen score that
while containing very high highs is just
riddled with hearing the same tracks
over and over and over again despite all
of this I don't think yamamoto's Kai
score is bad by any means I think as
long as we ignore the literal theft bit
some of his highlight tracks are among
the best music ever produced for the
show it is just there's a lot of
asterisks it really is hard to speak in
detail about his contributions to the
series Without a Baker's Dozen butts now
of course this all meant that poor toei
had burned through yet another failed
attempt at establishing a post-kukuchi
composer for the show they really just
couldn't catch a break could they Flash
Forward to 2012 and toriyama's pissed
off and rewriting Battle of Gods in the
name of avoiding Dragon Ball Evolution
2.0 with Yamamoto banished to the home
for infinite thieves Towing now has
another chance to find the de facto
modern Dragon Ball composer one that
will Define this modern era of Dragon
Ball and this man of course is norahito
Sumitomo
[Music]
at this point Sumitomo has been the
sound of Dragon Ball for a surprisingly
long amount of time he was introduced in
Battle of Gods a decade ago and the
positive reception there meant that he
has continued working on the series ever
since but just like those that came
before him his journey is a storied one
and one that didn't start off on the
best of terms his initial work on Battle
of Gods was largely well liked actually
whether it be the fun Slice of Life
sections or the insane grand piano
moments this sparse but memorable score
was a solid starting point for this
man's Dragon Ball Journey well I do
do give up
I've given all I've got Lord beerus but
there's still no way I can beat you
unfortunately for all Sumi here
FUNimation were hungry for mokai given
its huge success in the west and so toei
relented with Kai the final chapters
leading to our men needing to compose a
whole soundtrack for The buark alongside
the upcoming Resurrection F film as I'm
sure you can imagine that men's
schedules were tight and while Sumitomo
might be talented there's only so much
one can do in such a limited time frame
wow it's been so long I hardly recognize
you so uh how are things going as a
result both bukai and Resurrection F
scores were pretty significant steps
down only a few months following freezie
pop survival movie Dragon Ball got
itself a brand new anime I don't think I
need to tell you all what the production
schedule was like for that but yeah
while the show melted on her screens for
several months I think many of us forgot
that every aspect of the production was
affected by this disastrous environment
leading to just as many viral music
hilarities as there were animated ones
[Music]
[Applause]
there's a common sentiment that Sumitomo
got better as the show went on but if
you look at his lengthy history of
composing prior to Dragon Ball super you
will find music that seems completely
foreign to what you heard here and in
Kai absolute worlds of quality apart
where he was once a composer known for
Strings piano Rich textures just about
everything you could ask for his work on
Cayenne super was rough very synthetic
with music that matched the tone of the
scene being the rare exception rather
than the rule
[Music]
[Applause]
thankfully much like super animators
found the time to produce excellent work
as the schedule improved so did Sumitomo
and with each passing Arc his work began
to jump in quality in fact you could
argue it was a complete metamorphosis of
sorts as the Goku black Arc found itself
with a score completely overhauled from
what came before with the return of
traditional string and piano composition
Sumitomo brought about some of the most
iconic and Powerful music this franchise
had ever seen
[Music]
this transformation continued further as
the show hit its final stretch the
universe survival Arc what's important
to understand here is that Sumitomo
earned his music degree in the states
studying at the prestigious Berkeley
music College this man has been a
spectacular solo saxophonist for much of
his career and boy did he ever put that
to use in this Arc that big orchestral
sound from the black Arc was now
combined with an incredible Jazz
influence Flair achieving something that
I think often goes underlooked he
created an unmistakably unique sound I
think that's why this Arc music sits so
fondly in the fandom's minds too
Yamamoto tokunaga just about everyone
I've spoken on today has excellent
qualities but as far as Japanese
composers go I don't think anyone since
Kikuchi has managed to create something
so recognizable these Works weren't just
your average anime score these
distinctly inseparably were Dragon Ball
super foreign
by the time the Broly movie roll around
Sumitomo had hit critical mass taking
everything he built up in the TV series
he began to incorporate far heavier uses
of themes and motifs and produced a
score that even his loudest detractors
collectively agreed was genuinely
incredible it should be clear at this
point that Sumitomo is a remarkable
Talent who faced a terrible production
environment at the start of his Dragon
Ball Venture but he persisted putting
his all into the show and reinvented his
relationship with the property with each
passing Arc in a world where a few viral
online Clips can tarnish your entire
reputation Sumitomo Rose above it all
pushed through the hard times and came
out the other side with some truly
legendary works of art
thank you
wow what a crazy history this franchise
has right well there was a lot of people
to cover and yet the Keen among you
might have noticed a glaring Omission
with the release of Dragon Ball super
superhero the series gained yet another
composer naoki Sato and I won't be
covering him today but I hope based on
everything I've said here you could at
least understand why because his journey
may very well have only just begun we
don't know whether he will return for
any future Dragon Ball Productions but
if he does you can be pretty damn
certain that there is more path for him
to walk because ultimately music is Art
and all forms of artistic expression are
living breathing things a relationship
with art evolves those who continue
their Pursuits are constantly
Reinventing themselves and honing their
craft in order to deliver a more Earnest
version of themselves onto the screen
whether that be composing or
illustration or writing animation
whatever the craft they all share that
same heartbeat and I think that's why
these can composers resonate so
intimately with me every single one of
them barring Yamamoto were tirelessly
dedicated to their craft and assuming
they were given the chance emerged from
their time with dragon ball in a far
better place than where they started
Dragon Ball itself has been a wonderful
home for these artists it is uniquely
welcoming in its ability to house all
sorts of sounds and approaches and
really stands as an incredible Showcase
of those differences so what is the
sound of Dragon Ball well I think that
just depends on who you ask some will
say Kikuchi some will say Faulkner some
will even say Sumitomo and I think
that's just an absolutely wonderful
thing about Dragon Ball just as the
original story and art evolved over the
course of its lifetime so too has what
any given person can consider to be the
sound of Dragon Ball and so as I begin
to prepare the absolutely colossal
Dragon Ball Z review series I have in
store for you all next week
I will leave you with this quote a
deeply poignant quote from hobbyist
turned composer Nathan Johnson of all
people we all think creativity will
burst out of you and those moments
happen but they are Far and Away the
minority of the time the rest of it is
rolling up your sleeves and taking that
creative burst and making it something
useful there's a gross and maturing
process where you recognize that not
everything you say or do is good in fact
the majority of it is garbage but some
of it really is good thanks for watching
and I'll see you all next week
oh and this guy did the English
replacement score for GT we didn't talk
about that
[Music]